[Music]
we're all hoping that there's some
intelligent aliens trying to talk to us
sending us signals but just because we
want it to be true doesn't mean every
radio signal from space that we can't
immediately understand must be some
intelligent alien giving us recipes or
something so it requires sort of sort of
sensibility when you analyze these
signals there's a signal recently that
everyone got excited about especially
the press because we did not understand
it and we have to remember that just
because there's something you don't
understand doesn't mean the explanation
is something extraordinary that they
don't go together you see a light in the
sky moving and you can't explain it that
does not mean it's an intelligent alien
coming from another planet to come
that's in a flying saucer observing us
these are not equivalent statements just
say I don't know what it is and hang out
with the U in the UFO what is it you
stand for unidentified I don't know what
it is you're done end of conversation
you want to speculate fine but don't
believe don't think your speculation has
greater meaning and greater truth the
less you know about the light that
you've seen no no so so it requires some
sensibility about how quickly you'll
leap to a conclusion think of all the
objects in the sky that we couldn't
explain in the past that we ultimately
ended up explaining and none of those
explanations were it's an alien visiting
from another planet or an alien
signaling we discovered a new kind of
star that was giving radio waves that at
the time we didn't understand is it
little green men no it was a new kind of
star that's how this works
so if they're really intelligent they'll
figure out a way to know how to talk to
us in our own language the hey we're
over here look left here we are
a you know good luck with the Patriots
that year you know they'll be like
totally in our culture and they would
know how to talk to us I have no doubt
I'm ready for et to phone home or to
phone us I'm ready
we'll be there but I I bet you the day
aliens want to talk to us we'll know
it's not gonna be some farmer in this
backyard it's not going to be some lone
person to who saw an image we will all
know I have no doubt because if they
managed to come here or talk to us
they're going to be able to do it in a
big way with technology far beyond
anything we've been able to muster
[Music]